[Musique]
est ce que vous avez peur de l'avenir et
venir
ah si j'ai beaucoup mes grands parents
disent nous on s'en fiche c'est c'est
vous qui allez avoir pas parce que là on
est en train de tester ça va en
décadence et c'est très mauvais par
exemple cette bombe atomique
ça pourrait provoquer un tremblement de
terre terrible des raz-de-marée des
choses comme ça qui est puis à la
pollution aussi et ça c'est un problème
très sérieux il
il faut s'en occuper mais être non parce
que si jamais on ne trouve pas une
solution dans l'est je vais être
optimiste dans les 150 ans qui viennent
ça va être peut-être beaucoup plus grave
que ça n'est maintenant pas ce que ça va
être vraiment inquiétant j'ai un peu
peur de l'avenir parce que ton dit que
c'est vrai que la pollution après ça va
devenir poule en table et que paris tout
le monde dit aussi que dans 10 ans 15
ans à devenir comme new york en lui tout
comme le candidat méric faudra
s'enfermer chez soi faudra pas sortir le
soir après 8 heures parce qu'il y aura
des cambrioleurs mais j'ai peur que
paris devienne une ville très pollués
comme c'est vraiment bon
à la fin on portera des masques à gaz
est horrible mais par contre j'ai pas
peur des martiens parce que ce serait
égoïste de penser que dans d été des
galaxies énorme n'y a que nous qui ce
qui est ayant un mode une vie à peu près
normale et une respiration et tout ça
peut-être qu'il ya une autre terre ou
d'autres choses comme ça peut-être
qu'ils sont comme nous ils essayent de
rentrer en contact désespérément pour
avoir un mode pour avoir des
communications des des visites de chacun
des mondes des études parce que ça
serait annoncée déjà enrichissant ap à
étudier mais deux ce serait fantastique
[Musique]